i've had a a series of events
from the time i was a teenager
to when my son was born so i've had like
i've had like death threats i've i've
been at a
party where a fight broke out i got shot
at i've had you know guns pulled on me
and my friends this is when i was
younger
so i don't know like not many people
have all that stuff
happen you know to to them but i had
always
you know been a good shooter and i got
my concealed carry permit when i was 21
and i started
you know training here and there and
then i had an event with my son
where some guys were trying to run me
off the road and yelling at me a bunch
of guys in this truck i had no idea what
it was about
and i was you know i was scared i was
like what is this
what is going on and i had uh
i was like well i'm bj baldwin i'll just
drive away like nobody's gonna catch me
and i was in a truck that had a big
motor in it and i was just going to rip
through traffic and go through the
desert and leave these guys
i didn't have any gas i had like no
range left on on uh on the
the fuel gauge and i was like [ __ ]
okay well
[Laughter]
help me help me bleach
but yeah in that instance you know i had
my
gun on my other car and i had my son
with me it was a year old i was taking
him to lunch
then you got the [ __ ] you got your
[ __ ] kid in danger
man i know i know so i had no idea what
this was about
does this [ __ ] always just come to you
like the dangerous [ __ ]
is your like spidey sense of the game
there's no danger
i don't know i wish it didn't i wish it
didn't but yeah i
i had my gun in my other car because i
thought i don't know what this was about
there's like four or five people in this
car and they're yelling telling me they
were gonna kill me it's like damn
they're pretty upset
i ended up making it to this restaurant
and running my son in
i like sprinted to the restaurant and
ran my son and they came in behind me
and i came out to deal with it i gave my
son to the hostess and i came out to
to deal with it um and the guy was like
super apologetic he's like
oh my god i'm so sorry i didn't know you
had your son with you
and um you know i was behind
you and there was a little rock that
fell off and it broke my windshield and
i'm sorry i've had a
really bad day and i just shouldn't have
freaked out like that
and uh but after that you know
because you know in in my younger days i
might have
gotten out of the car you know and and
been like yo what's up
um and tried to deal with it and i could
have gotten knocked out my son would
have been
in there in my truck exposed to
you know the heat or something like that
and he could have he could have gotten
hurt so i was just trying to get away
and then after that i just started i
started doing a lot of
defensive tactics training and i never
left home without my gun after that
because because of my kids i just
it rattled around in my head like that
could have gone
way south you could have you know they
could have ran you off the road
killed your son or something these
people had me really really
uh concerned and i was helpless there's
nothing i could do but i had
no fuel usually i would just drive away
right right you know what what [ __ ]
that wants to run you off the road
is going to catch a world champion
driver like who's going to knock you out
in the club
nobody they punch in the face they'll
[Music]
die
you